melina
herzlich willkommen
ihr seht zu einem neuen video ich will
gar nicht lange um den heißen brei reden
ich bin hier mit alex kamera lässt sich
nicht so dass ich heute als video machen
wollte ist etwas was wir schon mal bei
seppel offenen kanal gemacht haben 32
mein name ist luca nelson drehe ich in
der kamera alex alex hat ein paar in
trost von youtube rausgesucht also
begrüßungen et cetera und er wird mir
jetzt rückwärts abspielen und ich muss
die quasi erwarten wenn ich das nicht
schaffe bin ich scheiße du schaffst das
schon ich bin eigentlich übel schlechtes
es hört sich an wie holländer
es hat sich einfach wie heute das ist
auf jeden fall gelernt die ich lese
meine titel der titel freue ich
überrasche dich zu hause
okay das heißt es ist auf jeden fall ein
mädchen das er mit raus gehören ich
überrasche dich zu hause ich würde sagen
da die connect sitze nicht gesagt er
würdigte nicht gewusst
[Musik]
waschke 37 uhr übrigens der erste titel
oder die ersten verfolger von titel sind
youtube am ende frage preisen also es
ist auf jeden fall ein typ das hört man
ja und ich hätte jetzt ob ich als erstes
gedacht apparat war das ein bisschen
tiefere stimme war allerdings der wird
nehmen wir machen youtube am ende die
richtige richtung aber wir sind ja
vielleicht wer weiß dass leute ihr könnt
ja selber mal mit raten also ihr könnt
ja wenn alexis abgespielt hat das
nächste mal einfach mal das video hier
pausieren und das in die kommentare
schreiben ob jetzt richtig gehabt hätte
[Musik]
zwei leute geredet dass es zwei personen
im intro ich dachte weil die alte es war
auf jeden fall mädchen und jungen
ich bin so schlecht ich habe jetzt eine
[Musik]
richtig stoppen schlug der oder die
youtube geworden ist schon seit
ewigkeiten damals reagierten titel how
to date
das ist nicht wahr als wenn das wintv
war nicht mehr da ist doch von tinte wie
diese dienten also ich weiss glaube ich
wenn du meinst wenn ich nur so deine
tipps betrachte aber muss die stimme
kann ich das überhaupt nicht irgendwie
dazu ordnen
ich sage es jetzt einfach mal coldmirror
das hätte ich an den stimme nie erwarten
nur weil du gesagt hast eine würde
youtube
mit dabei sind
channelpartner managerin bei meinem
netzwerk studio 71 und ich hoffe
wirklich keine videos von ihr und ich
höre jetzt selber fast nie videos aber
an der stimme der so die stimme ist
einfach mega man kann ja ja ja das ist
krass ich glaube alle leute wissen
irgendwie peters oder wer das verhindert
die ganze zeit war und ich komme einfach
über wieder größte unwissende spaß
ich dachte so dass weil das was jetzt im
ende kommt ist er quasi der anfang vom
video und deswegen hab ich gedacht weil
also hamann herforder verein über so war
deswegen aber das ist wieder so ein
schweres ding ich habe eigentlich schon
verpackt wegen hate crime also das kann
man jetzt nicht mehr als erraten zählen
aber lieber mal einen kleinen tipp 2 ich
habe überhaupt kein plan satz hört sich
an wie wunderbar ist und die
mainzelmännchen oder irgendwie sowas
wären 700 700.000 alter wie komme ich da
nicht drauf mit 700.000 ich kenne mich
da überhaupt nicht aus südkorea
nicht mal wenn ihr das gerade tut mir
leid aber ich will dich so ich schaue
nicht für videos aber das hätte sich
dass das endlich auch das werde ich nie
drauf gekommen was das kriege ich ja
selbst nicht ändert er seine begrüßung
das heißt es ist irgendwie sollen
wenn sie besonders länder an
ach ja stimmt das intro jahr überhaupt
keinen plan was wir hatten schon da die
daten die österreichischen wir hatten es
mit li na wird glaube ich nicht sein ist
es eine deutschen youtube mit
zweieinhalb bis drei millionen
[Musik]
ich wurde angezeigt fragezeichen verstoß
gegen das waffengesetz youtube mit mehr
als eine million abonnenten julia
beauties julia blutig oder angezeigt
weil sie gegen das waffengesetz
verstoßen ruf leute ausländischer
herkunft befragt
was also war ich weiß nicht mehr
zumindest vom namen her
1,1 millionen deutsche was jetzt kommt
der ist doch ausländischer herkunft oder
ich weiß nicht das was ihr vom video
meine damen und herren ich hoffe es hat
euch gefallen wenn es gedacht lassen
wenn es normal sehen wollt ihr findet
hier ein smiley eingeblendet wenn ihr
darauf klickt hört ihm einen kanal
abonnieren es ist kostenlos man geht ein
besserer mensch dadurch habe ich mir
sagen lassen und hier findet ihr
irgendein anderes video eingeblendet
also könnt ihr einfach mal drauf klicken
ja ich hoffe dass viele gefallen und